And for this,
mutual respect and trust had to appear. Trust does not
appear immediately when we came
to the president for the first time and then he
first started talking about patriots
about other weapons, definitely those were
our dreams then.
When our heroic Ukrainian nation
demonstrated this from the very first days of this
full-scale aggression and when
I think that no one predicted that we
would fight.
I believe that the most important thing today
is the support of the Americans. There has been a
historic change in the
attitude of the
Americans to Ukraine,
and I believe that it is impossible to change it in the
opposite direction. We see
support from two parties today.
Almost every week,
senators, congressmen,
representatives of American society,
who are representatives of both parties, and they
all support  Ukraine. I
hope and believe that the
historic rapprochement and
historic friendly partnership
between Ukraine and the United States
is not only today, it is for the long,
long future.
I remember how the Russian delegation behaved.
they tried to do it by military
means on
February 24. Last year, Ukraine will never
make any compromises
regarding the territorial integrity of
our country, there will be no negotiations with the
Russians until the moment when
their troops are here.
before spoke before
parliaments
universities if you fight for your And
here I believe that we are very similar to
Americans and if we
look at the history of the United States,
the same thing happened to you, you became a
huge great country a great
nation precisely because you always fought
for your independence for  your freedom and
values ​​have always been the main thing for you and
today in the 21st
century we are fighting for the same